Sono appena tornata dal festival del
cinema di Venezia e quindi comincerò a
dirvi del Cinema del cinema perché c'è
stato in questi film sono stati
presentati quest'anno c'è una costante
che ha abbracciato un po' tutti quanti
anche se affrontavano temi diversi e
cioè tutti esprimevano un disagio un
disagio in particolare dei giovani una
difficoltà nel trovarsi in questo mondo
dove non si trovano bene
non posso dire che venisse fuori
un'aspirazione un mondo diverso
c'era solo il disagio ma forte e mi sono
domandata perché come il cinema e così
Ma sapete che l'arte ha sempre una
caratteristica è un merito quello di
riuscire a intercettare con anticipo
tendenze che la politica per esempio
mette molto più tempo a capire
umori tendenze
qualche cosa che ancora non è visibile
Ma che verrà fuori e quindi mi è parso
un segnale interessante perché c'è
questo disagio Ma c'è un disagio perché
in questo mondo non stanno bene
Tant'è vero che ci sono fenomeni di
violenza giovanile di suicidi insomma
voglio dire ogni giorno la cronaca
riporta qualche cosa di questo genere
perché credo che sia diffusa la
sensazione che questo mondo non va bene
ma c'è una difficoltà a capire se
potrebbe cambiare e come e dunque credo
che sia importante riproporsi la domanda
che fare allora io comincio dalla
protesta perché credo che la prima cosa
da fare protestare soprattutto per una
cosa sul fatto che nonostante sia del
tutto evidente che questa epoca storica
sta finendo e le un'altra che non
sappiamo bene cosa sia e sono tornanti e
storici che Avvengono ogni
30/40/50 anni O magari anche in un
secolo per la prima volta e cioè sta
diventando evidente che il mondo di ieri
non può più essere conservato come era
anche con i vantaggi che abbiamo avuto
nel mondo di ieri ogni giorno Vediamo
i dati tremendi ero a Milano l'altro
giorno è venuto fuori il dato che a
Milano la temperatura era più alta di
quanto non sia mai stata nella storia
Apriamo la televisione e vediamo incendi
terremoti naufragi
nubifragi e così via E tutti i dati ci
dicono che il problema ecologico è un
problema enorme Eppure nessuno si occupa
si occupa pochissimo Si parla di bonus
per questo quest'altra cosa ma non si fa
nulla chiedendosi perché abbiamo bisogno
di bonus perché abbiamo bisogno di
correre a riparare delle cose che non si
possono più riparare Ora credo che la
consapevolezza
di quello che sta avvenendo sia la prima
cosa da fare quando ci si dice che il
giovane non si occupano di politica non
si occupano di politica perché questi
che sono i grandi problemi di cui
avvertono l'importanza non hanno alcun
riflesso nella politica ufficiale e nel
dibattito parlamentare E allora credo
che bisogna invece aiutare
a diventare consapevoli che qualche cosa
è avvenuto Ormai già 30 anni forse dalla
crisi Dal 72 73 quando ci fu la crisi
petrolifera è stato il primo segnale di
una crisi che non era più una crisi
congiunturale economica ma una crisi che
toccava il modello il nocciolo la
sostanza del nostro modello economico
e che si è fondato ormai da tanto tempo
sulla
delapidazione delle ricchezze naturali
l'omicidio della natura e che tutto
questo oggi non è più possibile e quindi
è una svolta che si impone non che si
deve dire è una svolta che Noi
proponiamo piuttosto che un'altra non si
può fare a meno di tenere conto che non
è più possibile un modello di sviluppo
che si fondi sulla rapina della terra e
questo è il primo punto Ma non è
soltanto questo ci si rende conto anche
grazie a questo che il nostro meccanismo
di sviluppo si è fondato sull'idea che
bisognava estendere sempre più sempre di
più
lo sviluppo industriale la produzione di
merci perché il profitto è stato tutto
ancorato alla successiva sempre maggiore
produzione
questa qui non è più possibile per le
ragioni ecologiche che ho detto ma anche
perché si è visto che l'idea l'illusione
che il modello diciamo occidentale
potesse espandersi a tutta la terra non
funziona e che
per ragioni di rapina E per ragioni
storiche e non si espande nel modo come
si era creduto bene Questo vuol dire che
dobbiamo cambiare modello vuol dire
cambiare modo di consumare modo di
produrre e quindi modo di vivere appena
si dice questo tutto reagiscono benzanti
diciamo ci volete fare tornare al
medioevo che non si sono più le comodità
i beni che noi possiamo oggi acquisire
Siamo tutti affascinati di tutti gli
oggetti superflui che si trovano al
supermarket e voi volete farci riportare
al saio Francescano dall'età della
pietra
credo che non ci sia niente di più
sbagliato di questo perché questo mondo
non va bene così come e quindi il
problema di trovare come cambiarlo ora
Io credo che se noi riusciremo a ridurre
la produzione di beni Completamente
inutili e a trasferire le risorse invece
su servizi sociali collettivi scuola
università ricerca ospedali quartieri
città dove si vive meglio riduzione del
tempo di lavoro sprecato e massacra la
gente per fare delle cose inutili ma è
forse il mondo sarà migliore e si può
essere migliore Paolo Carlo Marx e non
viene più citato è stato preso soltanto
per qualcuno che diceva la lotta di
classe la lotta di classe c'è perché
fino a che ci sono delle classi
sfruttate in un forte esserci una lotta
di classe ma Max dava anche una
prospettiva lei diceva che si sarebbe
potuto fare un mondo diverso in cui il
la felicità sarebbe stata misurata in
modo diverso ecco la felicità oggi viene
misurata col PIL no col prodotto lordo
non è così c'è un mondo molto migliore
che si può fare e questo è giovane lo
intercettano e cioè quello di consumare
in modo diverso di avere altre gioie
altri piaceri della vita
che è possibile voglio citare un libro
appena uscito un libro di un marxista
giapponese che insegna all'Università di
Tokyo che si chiama il capitale
nell'antropocene vale a dire il capitale
oggi il libro dice per l'appunto quello
che sto dicendo non si può più
continuare con questo meccanismo bisogna
che ci sia una decrescita ma la parola
decrescita non riguarda la decrescita
dei nostri piaceri
di crescita del profitto di un modello
di sviluppo che non va bene perché è
interessante questo libro perché ha
venduto 500 mila copie in Giappone
soltanto perché non è stata ancora
tradotto e hanno fatto un sondaggio e
hanno visto che il successo di questo
libro c'è stato soprattutto fra le
giovani generazioni che sono quelle di
cui il cinema intercettano gli umori e
che si cominciano gli si può ricevere
grandi problemi e allora come ho detto
bisogna protestare bisogna protestare
perché non è più pensabile una politica
che si occupa delle bollette del bonus
non perché non siano cose importanti
Certo quando bisogna fare qualcosa
nell'immediatezza bisogna fare questo ma
non si può continuare a fare delle cose
immediate senza forse il problema di
doversi va a finire senza una strategia
di lungo periodo e su questo la nostra
politica governativa sono dei gattini
ciechi e
non si può pensare che tutto sarà come
prima la cosa principale è che il mondo
peggiorerà rispetto a quello di adesso
che pure bello non è e Perché diciamo il
compromesso sociale Democratico quello
che ha consentito Welfare ha consentito
di redistribuire nei 30 anni felici del
dopoguerra una parte diciamo delle
risorse per le quali abbiamo avuto la
riforma sanitaria
le pensioni non sarà più possibile
perché se si riduce quel meccanismo e
non lo si cambia non ci sarà mai Infatti
lo vediamo non sono 30 anni che si
perdono il giorno un pezzo del Welfare
il servizio sanitario diventa sempre
meno buono anzi diventa brutto proprio e
che c'è sempre una salario
sono tornare oggi al pronto soccorso
Ecco forse una grande clinica come come
Policlinico Gemelli gli infe Oggi sono
tutti quanti presi in lavorano per ditte
di appalto pagati €5 all'ora Allora
voglio dire è pensabile un mondo così no
E allora bisogna prendere atto che c'è
bisogno di un pensiero lungo e i giovani
sono uno strumento fondamentale i vecchi
non hanno più pensiero lungo
piagnucolano che il mondo non è più come
prima come quello anche di 20/30 anni fa
questo io credo che sia il che fare di
oggi ed è un mondo possibile perché non
è vero che non è possibile vivere
sprecando meno risorse utilizzandole per
vivere meglio Certo bisogna fare una
rivoluzione io dico sempre che la mia
generazione era divisa fra quelli che
volevano fare la rivoluzione e quelli
invece che erano i social democratici
volevano andare piano pianino attraverso
il Parlamento passo alla volta quello
non è più possibile oggi una soluzione
non è più un'opzione psicologica una
scelta politica è obbligatoria perché
certo fare il cambio di cui c'è bisogno
c'è bisogno di una modifica profonda del
nostro sistema di vivere è una
rivoluzione individuale e una
rivoluzione del moto di funzionare della
società è una rivoluzione possibile
certo non si tratta di prendere il
palazzo d'inverno del resto se
prenderemo Palazzo Chigi non ci
troveremo dentro perché
la rivoluzione lo sappiamo bene che un
processo lungo
che si fa per tappe ma che si fa
avanzando non
occupandosi solo del presente
dimenticando Dove si va a finire Ecco
questa è la mia ricetta ma non è
soltanto mia Per fortuna è una ricetta
storica dalla sinistra Fra l'altro
perché la sinistra in crisi perché la
sinistra era stata capace di avere uno
sguardo lungo e oggi
le parole del Papa Il papa è fantastico
Io lo vorrei Presidente del Consiglio
due ministri del mondo perché dice le
due cose importanti dici prima di tutto
e che la guerra è una pazzia che non si
può fare questa guerra nel contesto che
ho descritto rischia di durare decenni
chissà quanto e porta la violenza nel
mondo già delinea dall'ucraina che è una
fase di passaggio uno scontro storico
fra la CIA e gli Stati Uniti e
l'occidente che vede di non essere più
il solo a poter usufruire delle risorse
del mondo e che diventa sempre più
arrogante e i popoli del resto del mondo
che non accettano più questo arroganza
il cambiamento lo vediamo diciamo
dappertutto Ecco la sinistra dicevo il
Papa il Papa ha detto bisogna ripartire
dal territorio cominciare ognuno a
pensare cosa si può fare nel proprio
quartiere nella propria città aprire
delle vertenze perché si facciano degli
investimenti per le risorse per
l'energia nel modo giusto e non cercando
di recuperare il passato le bollette si
sta lì a ridiscutere del gas l'Italia io
dico sempre i russi sono un gas i
sultanici hanno il petrolio l'Italia
avrebbe il sole il mare il vento l'acqua
e invece non lo facciamo facciamo tutto
il contrario quando l'energia
rinnovabili costano meno e si fanno in
meno tempo Ecco il Papa dice Ripartiamo
dal territorio però aggiunge subito
a condizione di conservare lo sguardo
sull'altrove con Che vuol dire malate il
nostro territorio è una cosa un comune
del deserto del saelle un'altra e quindi
si può pensare al proprio territorio se
si pensa contemporaneamente al resto del
mondo e quindi a fare qualcosa che non
vada bene soltanto per la nostra piccola
opportunità sono tante iscriversi alla
Lega ma invece pensare al nostro
territorio tenendo a mente Come è fatto
il resto del mondo e cosa bisogna fare
per salvare anche quello sono ottimista
perché
Perché frequento i giovani va bene Mi
hanno così stufato quelli delle
generazioni intermedie gli ex-68ni che
piangono E basta che frequento soltanto
i giovani Loro sono gentili mi fanno si
fanno frequentare Ma quando dico giovane
dico al di sotto dei 23 anni che già a
25 sono perduti Ecco perché con i
giovani e trovo anche una grande
politicizzazione Non è vero che i
giovani sono politicizzati semplicemente
non gli interessa la politica ufficiale
quella delle istituzioni preferiscono
fare da soli per questo sono ottimi